Justin this morning a
stunning jobs
report shows
2024 has kicked off with a bang.
353,000 jobs were added last month.
That is a much stronger gain
than expected.
The report comes
just days after the Federal Reserve
kept interest rates on hold
for the fourth time in a row.
And Fed
Chairman Jerome
Powell says he's encouraged
about the healthy economy.
Joining me now
for all of this,
you always come on the good times.
I love to see it
all the credit I'm taking all the credit.
Solomon is here.
She's been waiting for these numbers.
They just dropped.
Give us an example of what
we're looking at. Yeah.
So good to be with you, my friend.
So 353,000
jobs added in the month of January,
as you said. Stunning.
This is twice, twice what Wall Street
economists were expecting.
The expectation was closer
to 176,000 Unemployment rate holding
steady for the third month
in a row at 3.7.
If this feels familiar, it's
because it has been
we have been in this range.
And you look over the last few years
or so,
we've been under 4%
for the last two years,
at least two years.
If you look at at 4% or lower
even longer than that.
So when we look at sort of the industries
or sort of how we compare
this month, January to the prior month,
December was revised up
in a very big way.
November was revised.
I know you hear
John sort of like, wow, way over there.
I mean, it it is very shocking.
November was revised up slightly.
So this was a
it was a stronger year
than we had even expected. Right.
And when you look at the industries
where we added jobs in January,
I thought this was
sort of interesting, too.
So an area
where we hadn't seen a ton of job growth
in 20, 23.
Sort of those white collar jobs
are professional
and business services
adding 74,000 jobs in January.
To put that in context.
And 2023
the average
per month was closer to 14,000.
Wow. So that is that's a pretty big huge.
Exactly. Health care.
Now that is a continuation
of what we saw last year
adding 70,000 jobs
and retail adding 45,000 jobs in.
Erica Hill
made the great point in the last hour
that when you think about retail
you know about people shopping.
That's right right
and so
if people
are adding to their sort
of retail payrolls it would
it would see consumers very excited
Schumer is there.
So this is all just again
another sign of a labor market
that continues to show
some real signs of strength.
What investors may not be as happy with
is this suggests
that when we do see rate cuts in 20, 24,
they may be later in the year.
Right.
Right
we heard how the inflation game right.
Trying to figure that out.
Yeah exactly.
And we heard Jay Powell
earlier this week
say that March is really
not their base case.
They're not expecting a March rate cut.
But they will look at reports like this
as they decide when is the right time.
So a report like this
makes a rate cut look more likely
in the summer.
Okay.
So, you know,
little people are
looking at buying homes.
So this is what they are watching.
They're watching to see
if that rate comes down exactly.
But if you're feeling hot, Sarah,
it's getting hot in here.
Yes, exactly.
And surprisingly, one said,
yeah, it's
because the labor market
is still showing some some heat.
Okay.
Well, she always brings the heat,
everybody.
Rachel Solomon,
also, the reason
why John was jumping up and down is
I think he was like on his floor
when Kate was actually when
I'm fixing
I know this
this is this fixing economy right now.
Nothing to say to that in a good way.
Consistently,
consistently just exceeding expectations
by a ton. And
it is so hot
is so hot that in a brand new CNN poll,
we are starting to see
these relentlessly positive
job numbers have an impact
perhaps on attitudes here. Look at this.
All right.
We asked things going
well in the country today.
35% say things are going well.
No, that is not a great number.
When you look at it
in a vacuum, however, it ties a two year
high in some of the opinions over
the last two years have been quite low.
21%.
So this is a lot higher than it has
been over the last two years.
You break it down by party,
it's a similar story.
62% of Democrats
things think things are going well.
That's a big increase from the fall.
32% of independents again.
Not a great number,
but an increase from the fall.
14% of Republicans
think things are going well.
A low number, but again,
double what it was in the fall.
How is Joe Biden
being given credit for this?
Well, a little bit more.
Again,
how is Joe Biden handling the economy
right now?
37% approve of the way he's
handling the economy.
Again, not a great number in a vacuum,
but up from what it was in November.
So you're starting to see these numbers
move a little bit in the direction
the White House would like to see.
How have Joe Biden's policies affected US
economic conditions?
A very similar story.
Worsened conditions.
55% a number that you trouble
the White House
but moving in the right direction
for them since August improve conditions.
26% again moving up from August
had no effect stays the same.
Finally, again,
if you are the Biden
reelection campaign,
you're excited
that you are seeing improvement.
But this number right here.
How is your financial situation
changed in the last year
still even
with all these positive numbers
we are seeing?
42% of people
say their economic condition
has worsened in the last year.
That is what they are saying.
They feel what
the White House has to hope
is more positive numbers
like the one Helen, Sarah,
we're just talking about right there.
Moves this number even lower.